you're gonna have to bear with me on
this one folks the next demo is for
slender the arrival and I if you know me
you know that I'm like really terrible
when it comes to horror games
fortunately Casey Lynch the VP of
publishing at midnight City is here to
be my rock to possibly hold my hand if I
need it we didn't discuss this but I'm
gonna put you on the spot if it comes to
that I'm happy to accommodate Thank You
Casey
welcome to the stage excited to have you
here all right midnight City you guys
have a bunch of games here at e3 this is
the first of a couple we're gonna see on
the game SWAT live stage show and it's
slender the arrival a game that many
people have already played yeah so I
ain't been terrified by that's right
yeah I mean it's real popular game on
Steam yeah youtubers love to play it and
scream and so including our own Jeff
McDonald and zouri and Harley on games
Watts house of horrors you guys have
been a favorite on there well so what
we've done is we've taken the game that
we released last year at Halloween on
Steam and we've added new content and by
we I mean blue Isle Studios who's the
developer sure they're a toronto-based
developer five-person team really really
great team so hey guys uh blue sky wild
blue blue Alex Brendan Garrett Daniella
and Ashley so got it
but yeah so there's new content we're
gonna show one of the new levels alright
and as we go through it I'll tell you a
little bit about what's going on and
let's get into it cuz this is the
perfect setting for me to play one of
these games loud a lot of people around
and lots of lights on and somebody with
me so but slender you know when it first
sort of came out it was the eight pages
and I it really touched off this is kind
of Renaissance of indie horror games I
feel like it really caught people's
imaginations in a remarkable way where
it was all anyone could talk about for a
while so slender the arrival sort of a
more full-fledged experience or longer
one at least and now with new contents
give people a little background on
slender if maybe they have never played
it because they don't like to soil
themselves sure so when the original
slender the APA just came out I was game
done by a guy named parsec
and it was a pretty self-contained small
free to play experience and basically
you walked around an environment you
picked up these notes and with each one
that you picked up your presence was
made a little bit more known to Thunder
mad yeah and which would inevitably
results in him hunting you down and
scaring the crap out of you so so what
blue I'll have done is they've taken
sort of that premise and they flushed it
out into a full story where we're
learning more about the the mythology
and the the past of the character and
the people that have been involved with
Thunder man okay with sort of how it
became to be this thing or what where he
has is it more like tracing the path of
carnage and horror in his wake um a
little bit really it's more about the
people that that are sort of left behind
are trying to put the pieces together so
like well in fact what we're seeing
right now for instance is a character
named CR and he's he's looking for clues
as to what happened to a boy that had
gone missing named Charley Matheson jr.
and so he's actually up at this farm
which was owned by the masses and family
years and years and years ago you'll
notice to you up in the upper right hand
corner it keeps blinking VCR play yes
what that means is we're actually
playing through content that's on a
videotape that another character has
found at a different point in the game
so earlier in the game you're playing as
a woman named Lauren oh and so she comes
across these tapes and so one of them
goes into the the VHS player and now
we're friends playing there you are
watching yeah so cool CR is a guy that
that also is referenced over the course
of the rest of the game three different
notes and letters and like like this for
instance so here we've just found this
letter that doesn't look like a very
great thing looks like a bunch of
children slender losers why hang out at
school with their teacher on fire right
I mean yeah totally pleasant experience
thank you us but yeah so I mean the
experience of slender their arrival it
does a little bit about fleshing out
more the story for who Slenderman is but
but again really it's trying to sort of
trace the steps of the characters that
have disappeared who
been affected by slender to try and put
the whole picture together so so see
ours going through this this farm right
now trying to find clues as to what
happened to this little boy Charlie so
when the game came out on Steam there
there was additional content that was
added that that that told the story
about Charlie a little bit more you
actually kind of came into contact with
what Charlie became I don't want to
spoil it so because that's in this game
as well but for the Xbox 360 and
PlayStation 3 version there is this new
content this is a level called homestead
so this is one of the new levels and so
this you know you're getting to know
these different characters or at least
their perspective in their connection
and you know this this particular point
well it just got dark but it you know
it's sort of a slow burn it seems like
in a lot of ways in terms of pacing you
know and that's I think so integral to
to an experience it's going to be deeply
unnerving or that's going to sort of
have some horror wait is this like let
you get into the world then starts to
like get you a little off kilter like
pacing is so integral to the experience
it is and and you know that's driven by
the exploration you trying to find these
different clues and as you find them you
know what you're learning as you're
paying attention and as you get to know
the characters in the backstory it adds
to that sort of kind of slow burn slow
crawl tension because so for instance as
we've been talking it's been hard to
kind of pay attention but so in the
initial the the barn that you went into
you found a note where there were these
girls talking about going down to play
in a cellar and so we're going to see
them reference a little bit later the
this guy CRS he's wandering around here
he just looked into this granary silo
and the lights didn't work there's a
generator that looks like it's at a gas
he just found a note that said that all
the supplies are in the cellar so
putting you know two and two together
now or we're wandering out into this
field looking for this cellar that we
already know these little girls went to
go play hide and seek into we found a
note with you know Slenderman and some
fire and some kids and oh goodness sakes
so now we're looking for the cellar and
I'm sure nothing good will will happen
yeah yeah just gonna find a bunch of
rotten potatoes
some old vegetables and everything's
gonna be cool you know to your point
about like the slow burn I mean if you
look at the presentation it's it the way
that the guys have have crafted the game
it's it's you know even like right now
it's almost sunset it's in that sort of
like twilight hour where the the sun's
just leaving and yeah there's nothing
going on and we're about to make our way
down to this very inviting warm cellar
absolutely well quick reminder to you
folks that we are taking questions via
Twitter and the GameSpot chat for all
our live demos all throughout III just
tweet with the hashtag GameSpot III or
go into that GameSpot chat and leave a
question for us we've already got some
folks commenting on the demo Loren
Greyjoy specifically commenting on the
new level that doesn't really feel like
she could play because the protagonist
is also called Loren and that's just a
little too close to home for her well in
this new level the protagonist is CR and
in the huh
- dude so maybe she'll say she come on
in this one it's no problem
plus we love great choice you know I
mean come on you got you got to play a
little slender which is coming they do
not so Casey they do not so I you know I
think what one of the neat things I'm
sort of imagining here with the VCR play
mechanic is that it allows you guys to
maybe get a little playful with some
effects once you get down you know not
just a flickering light of this what is
certain to be quite an elaborate cellar
but also why you cellar this is yes this
is more than just your ID store some
sports equipment down there and for sure
because I mean this was a family that
made their living off of the land so if
you saw the the huge granary with all
the silos I mean this was a production
farm so I mean they kept all their
supplies down here you can see the
drawings on the wall I mean there was a
family here so these kids they would go
down and play and it made sense you know
as a family to go do these things but
not knowing of course that evil was a
foot just didn't make sense as a family
to put down a reliable electrical wiring
system so that this flick
doesn't happen all the time well yeah
now also I guess it's been a while it's
been a long while and as you know as we
seen as we're going to collect sort of
more mementos and notes and pictures
we're gonna see that you know that
people haven't lived at this farm for a
really really long time
so now he's again what he's doing is
he's looking for this missing boy named
Charlie yeah we if we had been playing
through the entire game we would have
already encountered Charlie at another
point I don't want to give anything away
to have a little bit more context for
Charlie and yeah that would be
contributing to the whole your knowledge
of the situation and your foreboding
yeah so you're feeling pretty confident
that you're gonna find something down
here and you're gonna but you know blue
while they do a really good job of just
messing with you Oh God oh yeah wow that
was just a mannequin because they
fashion designers Oh God so what we're
doing down in the cellar again is we we
can't get the lights on in the greenery
so we're looking for fuel so that's what
we just did down dr. Gaskin it's not her
gas tanks we should all a couple like
did we see something maybe we did maybe
we didn't I don't know I mean that's
sort of what slender is is yeah it pops
in just enough to say like oh my gosh
and then it's gone so so now we're
making our way back to the granary to
put the fuel in the generator to see if
we get the lights on so we can go in
there and see what the heck's going on
we've got some folks offering advice to
not go in there get out of there now
says Liam O'Leary
Liam a man after my own heart but no we
have to because this is the new stuff
and slender the arrival that folks have
been so curious to see I was checking in
on blue Isles Facebook page before the
demo and people are just clamoring for
any little glimpse of the new content
they begin yep I mean this is it right
here so yeah I mean the fan base is it's
a wild I mean they they really really
get into the game so yeah and this this
content is actually going to come to
steam as well wait oh I thought you know
I honestly there were two two-bit frames
that it was in that and I was like no
that's probably just a cornstalk the
first time but then the player turn back
oh no that was oh oh oh god really well
we got a runaway now Oh what is that
seems like a little close yeah like
you're playing in a little go at any
given time if
if one of those things actually gets
close to us we'll die
so we want to try and avoid that CR will
stop well I guess no that's the V start
will stop at some point and then maybe
he'll regain another character sort of
thread which is kind of an interesting
way to structure sort of the
interweaving of these different well
yeah the the levels are presented in
different ways this is just one of the
ways that that it's presented but it's
also it mean it's like I said it's tied
in to the overall story so as you've
been playing through you're already
familiar with these other characters and
and now playing is CR again you know
he's been referenced as somebody who's
been leaving these different notes
behind and is a friend of these other
characters that you've been getting to
know so we just put the fuel into the
generator you know a lot of good it did
for lighting this place up but yeah Oh
everything's fine now we do have a
little more light so we're gonna go in
here and look around if we can find some
more clues about where Charlie went so
slender the arrivals coming to xbox 360
ps3 steam
it's already on steams already on Steam
yeah so it'll be on Xbox 360 Playstation
3 there's new content and does that new
content coming to steam as well the new
content will come to steam just as a
thank you you know for everybody that
bought it since it launched and on
Halloween up until now and so all the
Steam users will get that content
and so slender as you mentioned before
had just sort of had this this cult
following and this these fans and it
just like really caught on in a
remarkable way do you guys excited to
see how that takes place on consoles how
do you think it will it'll transition to
you know maybe with a console someone's
sitting a little bit a little further
away they've got you know they they're
in their living room as opposed to their
dead you know how do you sort of
expecting the transition to consoles to
be for slender I mean it's a different
audience I mean there's a lot of
crossover between Steam users and people
who play xbox and playstation but there
is a a core group of people who identify
themselves very clearly as console
players so it's gonna it's gonna be in
front of more people plus it is a
different experience it's opened up a
little bit more I mean I still think the
best way to play it is with all the
lights off
oh yeah and with headphones of course so
but you know for people who want to turn
off the lights on and sit a little bit
farther back
they can have that experience as well
that's the only way you're gonna get me
to see for this game Casey I don't know
that
so you notice it's now sunset and it's
getting a little dark that has gone down
I like that that that sort of the Bob of
the Sprint coming it has this off-kilter
feeling to it it's just yeah like
there's there's a lot of forces at work
here to sort of draw the player in and
maybe put them ill at ease let's see one
of the game mechanics too is as you
progress and as you either discover new
things or as you progress through you
know uncovering facts about the story
and make it farther into each level
slender is slowly but surely kind of
honing in on you as are sort of his
other minions or proxies so as we were
talking instead of going back to the
silo and putting the gaps in the
generator what we did is we walked over
here first when we realize that this
gate that was leading over to the chapel
was locked and so outside of the granary
where we just were we found a key you
know so now we've been able to open this
and now we're coming into the graveyard
there's a chapel and so we're starting
to put some of these pieces together
look like that all the time we have for
the demo here kitchen so so nothing good
is probably gonna come from this now
here's a note from Freda Matheson we
know this is the Matheson farm we know
that Charlie Matheson is the son that's
disappeared now we're finding who's not
a creepy doll Little Walter Matheson
little Walter you know what's your heart
all these notes the pictures we can see
that this family lived here a long time
ago so now we're picking up toys again
we were on the hunt for a missing boy so
Oh Oh God what I didn't even see it
thank you that was I think I was I think
I was just like oh no it was the man
that oh okay that's my but it doesn't
seem to see you
okay okay so I saw you and there we saw
you Casey
so now you've been introduced to Charlie
and you got to go in some slender man
and you started picking up his toys we
expect never steal a freaky dead child's
toys right all right Casey slender the
arrival of midnight city bringing that
to consoles this fall do you guys have a
date no what's your units coming this
summer even soon ya real soon probably
through the next couple months we'll
have an official date to announce here
pretty quick fantastic well thanks so
much for coming on stage talking about
slender guiding me through it you're a
you're a helpful guy you didn't play
with my emotions too much I thank you
thank you for having us